yo creo que ya estamos listos para
atacar ejemplos un poco más complicados
así que déjenme dibujar algo aquí medio
loco digamos que tengo algo así y
digamos que les sale una ramificación
digamos así muy bien entonces ahora en
este vídeo vamos a tratar de ponerle
nombre a esta molécula verdad así que
vamos a ver cuáles son o más bien cuál
es la cadena más larga posible verdad y
si empezamos por ejemplo de aquí
tendríamos 1 2 3 4 5 6 verdad de este
punto a este tendríamos no perdones 1 2
3 4 5 años si son 66 átomos de carbono
en esta parte ahora si nos vamos a este
lado tendríamos 7 y 8 pero si nos vamos
hacia arriba tendríamos 7 8 9 10 verdad
y por otro lado si empezamos aquí y
terminamos acá sería 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 así
que nuestra cadena más larga será esta
que estoy pintando con verde
ok y que tiene 10 átomos de carbono eso
significa que esta estructura al menos
su digamos su estructura principal es de
un decano verdad entonces esto va a
tener en su nombre decano muy bien ahora
bien tenemos que enumerar esto de tal
suerte que este este grupo alquiló se
encuentre en el menor orden posible
verdad y se encuentra más cerca de este
extremo que de este otro así que
empezamos desde aquí 1 2 3 4 5 se
encuentra en el quinto carbono ahora
cuántos cuantos átomos de carbono tiene
esta estructura de aquí este grupo
alquilo pues podemos ver que tiene dos
así que esto será un un un estilo en el
quinto carbono eso significa que se va a
llamar 5 útil decano verdad quizás lo de
dibujo
lo escribimos y separado pero bueno
vamos a ver qué tal si pintamos algo
todavía más loco digamos esta misma
estructura
más o menos así y digamos que le ponemos
este mismo grupo de tilo y aquí le vamos
a poner otro grupo de tilo muy bien
entonces cuál sería el nombre de esta
estructura fin fíjense muy bien que
nuevamente nuestra cadena más larga es
este decano verdad así que vamos a
ponerle decano
y ahora tenemos que hallar una forma de
nombrar a esta molécula distinguiendo
estos dos grupos de ti lo que hemos
dibujado verdad tenemos este y este otro
entonces si nos fijamos se encuentran en
el 100 numerados digamos de esta forma
aquí podemos encontrar el primer grupo
de tilos y que es lo que nos da la la
digamos la enumeración de esta de esta
cadena de carbonos y podemos ver que
tanto en el quinto como en el sexto
carbono de nuestro de nuestra cadena
principal tenemos el grupo de tilo así
que vamos a nombrarle a este 56 verdad
que están tanto en el 5 como en el 6
verdad dietil y esto significa que
tenemos dos grupos estilo verdad y
nuestra cadena principal es el decano
así que ahí tienen una nueva forma de
nombrar moléculas cuando tienen diversas
ramificaciones